Brooklyn in the house
welcome everybody hear me
welcome did you hear that there you go
Brooklyn in the house this is thanks for
coming out and giving us your Friday
night this is a special presentation of
Startalk Startalk at BAM and in this
presentation you're gonna get three
versions of what our Startalk franchise
is all about the first one lasting 30
minutes is Startalk start start talk
lack ship all right where I am the host
and we have special guests talking about
special topics we then go to another 30
minutes featuring star talk all-stars
and that's where we have a cadre of
counterparts to me who are experts in
other fields of science and they each
have their own sort of radio show with a
comedian similar format but they get to
do it their way
Startalk all-stars you'll get a sampling
of that for 30 minutes and then we will
end with one of our favorite new
franchises of Startalk Startalk playing
with science which is all about the
science of sports and tonight we're
gonna talk about the physics of figure
skating and we'll get back to that in a
minute right now we will begin star talk
at BAM I'll bring out my comedic co-host
the one the only Chuck nice come on out
yeah somebody oh man I like it man this
is my man hi seven it's good to see you
very cool
and so tonight we're gonna talk about
the physics of the early universe and I
realized wait this was this whole event
was introduced as a a radio love fest
but but but he didn't say it right you
got say a radio right yeah exactly I
think you just made the universe
pregnant a love fest let me introduce a
colleague and a friend one of the
smartest people on earth theoretical
physicist Brian Greene everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
bright green best known for sort of
popularizing concepts like string theory
and the multiverse just made string
theory pregnant your best-selling author
the elegant universe a beautiful book
give it that one put that pearl read
your mouth right there person read your
book I know the rest of your just posers
so that was followed with a fabric of
the cosmos yeah beautiful book hidden
reality was a third book and then you
are a co-founder of the world science
festivals right got co-founder it's a
bit audacious to call the world science
festival if they're gonna call it the
universe but you know pulled it back to
work that's just great it's it's a world
science festival held in New York that's
just I'm just saying that's it also in
Australia so it is world in that way
okay all right head co-founded with your
wife that's Chris very good man you know
so Brian what there was recent news of
the earliest star ever formed in the
universe yeah
so we're on top of that story I've been
following it yeah yeah yeah because what
we know from as astrophysicists is you
get the big bang got that okay ah then
yeah the Cosmic Microwave Background got
that but nothing it's formed yet you got
to make stuff that you can recognize in
modern times and there's this long
period hundreds of millions of years
where nothing is happening and so we
call that the cosmic Dark Ages that's
ever dark ages and let me hear dark dark
yeah there you guys have a given replay
so the Dark Ages before the first stars
had formed so there was the hunt the
eternal hunt can we find that first star
and recent news announcement said what
well there's now evidence that those
first stars may have formed about 180
million years after the Big Bang
and it's hard to find them because
they're not actually sitting out there
waiting for us to see them directly you
have to find an indirect test to see
their presence by virtue of their impact
on their environment and in a very
clever experiment that's what was done
how do they do that experiment well you
mentioned the cosmic microwave
background radiation right I think I
mean just people know what that is this
is here yeah listen because there are
some people like at home listening that
may not know you know I'm just saying
you know for their sake maybe you should
tell them this is this is heat left over
from the Big Bang the Big Bang is very
hot as the universe expands it cools
down but the heat doesn't disappear it's
still there and indeed we can see that
heat coming to us through powerful
satellite porn telescopes today now that
is a fantastic discovery in its own
right that won the Nobel Prizes the
discovery of the microwave background
radiation but now imagine this it's one
of Nobel Prize twice that's true yes
absolutely yeah the initial discovery
and then I got to tell you that's very
good the same the same thing just like
five years later oh my god that was a
badass thing we found in the universe
yeah okay and was found by mistake right
so you do know about this man you said
mistake before I did well I didn't mean
to yet so - how did they see their
cousin my background tell us this well
the the theory was that when these
initial stars formed they would be very
large much larger than the Sun and very
hot and they would have emit a lot of
ultraviolet radiation and that radiation
would have had an impact on the
environment a lot of hydrogen around it
would have ionized hydrogen why does
that matter when you cause the hydrogen
to change in that way it has an impact
on the microwave background radiation
that otherwise would have passed through
it pass through it with no incident no
end
and now it's got it's been perturbed
that's right now actually some of it
gets absorbed which means when we look
out there should be missing parts of the
spectrum okay that are being absorbed by
this hydrogen which itself is being
affected so we're not seeing the stars
themselves we're seeing us some kind of
smoking gun of the stars yeah we're
seeing a shadow in some sense of the
stars oh my god it's just like the
Russia investigation so Chuck I didn't
tell you the reason why we have such big
bang expertise mm-hmm because we have
both independently appeared on the Big
Bang Theory
well sure actually actually I was only
on once we want only on once yeah oh
they didn't write you back now that
welcome to my world I thought you did
really well I thought you did I'm so not
an actor and I depend on people allowing
a little latitude for that cameo
non-actor delivered lines yeah you know
it's okay they're not really an actor
but we lit a slide you were good
well thank you hey listen Sheldon gave
both of us a hard time he did right he
told me that I should give up physics
and consider reading to the elderly
he said don't read your own books today
yeah he was pissed off that I was an
accessory to the demotion of Pluto Pluto
yeah he said Pluto was one of his
favorite and you told him to get over it
to get over it yeah yeah yeah but that
it's but he scripted to just get angry
so he jokes got angry yeah yeah I
couldn't rely on a natural response
that's because he's not real
[Laughter]
so so Brian this so this early star does
it tell us something backwards towards
the big bang that we should know about
well because you're a Big Bang guy yeah
it does I mean the curious thing is that
the signal is stronger than the theory
predicted so the signals there in the
sense that you got this missing part of
the spectrum so you have people saying
what would a first star look like let's
map it out yeah you compare it and now
we got something stronger than that
that's right so that means you got to go
back and recalculate what you've got to
tweak the theory and people are
suggesting that Dark Matter may play
yeah we did that hero this week tweak
yeah right so I don't know what he's
cooking up what what he he's just
tweaking stuff but the tweak also kind
of spilled over into the dark matter so
I'm not sure what this means okay I
don't know what either of you talk okay
so what of the Big Bang do you have to
tweak in order to allow our our
hypothesis to match the other well it
may be that the Dark Matter interacts
with ordinary matter in a way that
differs from the conventional
description this is very speculative
we're right at the beginning of this
kind of experiment at what point do you
say I need to tweak my theories and at
what point do you say I need to throw
out my well that's the art that's the
art of science you know and you know
some people criticize scientists for
sticking to theories long after the data
seems to suggest that they really need
to move on people say that even about
string theory they're wrong but yeah so
it's it's an art and it's a personal
choice I've to his face just to be clear
cuz I'll say this again publicly but I
did really say this to his face oh snap
what when I asked Brian I said Brian I
remember y'all for like from the that
old from the 1980s a string theory was
being born and I said wow this is great
a new understanding of the universe grat
general relativity married with quantum
physics of marriage that Einstein died
trying to find how soon will you have
this that what about five years out
about
years and then 10 years later how how
far do well be done at another five
years and then ten years after that just
another five years I'm consistent hey be
here 2018 Brian how about five years how
closer it is and it's like so then I
said I said so so Brian why he said
what's a hard problem so then I said or
every one of you working on this problem
is an idiot he did I said that to his
face
Brian I'm gonna go with hard at what
point you know I said that you know real
jokingly at what point do you say we're
simply not smart enough to even answer
the question we ourselves posed yeah
or do you just say it's hard because
Einstein I got our general relativity
basically by his lonesome in ten years
after he had special relativity yeah and
you've got how many dozens of you guys
and yeah for 35 years yeah yeah
well look I got to tell you the reason I
accept it to be on the show tonight is
okay I'm finally willing no here's the
situation if we were not making progress
then I wouldn't need you to tell me to
give it up right I don't believe in
reincarnation I think you live once and
I don't want to spend my life working on
a theory if I really don't think it has
the promise to reach the goal that we
have set for ourselves so you're honest
with yourself I'm totally honest I think
we have so much in common because I
don't believe in it because I don't want
to be a turtle
okay unbelievably incarnation for some
reason I think I'm coming back here yeah
yeah yeah yeah and you're the [__]
[Laughter]
what is the thing before they did not
get that oh they did you know I was
thinking the turtle was a reference to
the sort of the Hindu on the back of an
elephant and the elephant standing on
Turtles and his Turtles all the way down
see that's why you got doctor in front
of your name and tell dick jokes so
where were we
I know exactly where I'm sorry go ahead
I know exactly where we were so what I'm
asking you
theoretical physicist leading
theoretical physicists we have an
observation an astronomical observation
and it forces you to go back Andreea
tweak are you tweaking big bang you're
tweaking quantum physics you're tweaking
what are you tweaking well in this
particular case you really are tweaking
something that we yet don't understand
fully which is dark matter so that's
right for being tweaked but look they're
a dark matter is like mysterious gravity
of the universe we have no idea what's
causing it but I'll give you another
example which has happened recently
right there been measurements of the
rate of the expansion of space and those
measurements very recently are seeming
to be incompatible with earlier
measurements done in a different way
obviously had a whole other recent
result a whole other fold exactly and
this one if it's correct this is one
that could really change our
understanding of the early universe
dramatically right in order to get the
measurements that are done on the
expansion of space looking at the
microwave background radiation and those
that are coming from looking at
supernova explosions to get those
compatible right now is going to require
perhaps tweaking the dark energy it may
require tweaking our understanding of
the gravitational force I mean there are
many
that may come into that particular
weapon silly understanding of the
gravitational force itself yeah I mean
whenever you talk about dark energy
right everyone knows what dark energy is
yeah well I'm just saying some people at
home may not energy filling space that
we believe yields a repulsive gravity
that's causing the universe to speed up
in its acceleration and when it
theoretically should be slowing down
it's alright sorry ordinary gravity
pulls things together it can't be
slowing down okay the shock that we got
in 1998 is that it's not slowing down
and the rate of expansion is speeding up
against the wishes of gravity and well
here's the thing we didn't understand
gravity well enough gravity cannot only
be attractive it can be repulsive and
that really wasn't taken into account
until about 1998 when it comes to
cosmology now the possibility is maybe
this outward push is itself getting
stronger over time and so that means
thinking it was one thing would be an
incomplete understanding of that
phenomenon yes and actually change
everything but that's as which is why
you have to tweak and string theory yeah
so if it affects gravity then every
moment of our models from the Big Bang
forward would have to be rethought put
back in the computer say now what are
you gonna give me with this new
understanding literally because these
equations are so complex there's so many
features that come into play that you
have to put it on a computer and
simulate and see what happens okay so
now does that affect any thinking of
what's going on before the universe
began well I mean people play with those
sorts of ideas but it's hard to know if
that question even makes sense right it
makes sense to say what happened before
you were born what happened before the
earth formed those sorts of phenomenon
certainly were preceded by something
else in the universe but the Big Bang
may have been not just the beginning of
the universe as we think of it as stuff
it could have been the beginning of time
itself
this past Sunday we aired
our my interview with Stephen Hawking
went to the dudes office in Cambridge
and one of I asked him what was around
before the Big Bang
he gave an answer and nobody understood
the answer yeah so now you check it out
on life you don't yet so so I have no
idea of what it was what was he saying I
have no idea yeah I haven't seen the
podcast you got to watch the show yeah I
will yeah you didn't prepped me on this
flame what he was saying so so no but
you can give me two or three ideas that
you have about what preceded the Big
Bang absolutely so whether or not
through your idea yeah I mean one idea
is that the Big Bang may not have been a
unique event there may have been many
big bangs giving rise to many universes
we are one of them and we're just one of
the sort of like a cosmic bubble bath of
universes and we're just one bubble
expanding in that larger landscape of
reality if that's the case then our Big
Bang was not the beginning of everything
it was just an interesting event that we
hold dear because it gave rise to us but
there would have been a time before it
that wouldn't have been any more exotic
than the time now a time measured by
some methods we have yet to divine
because every method of measuring time
exists within this unit that's right so
the notion of a time going across all of
the universe is a very difficult idea to
make mathematical sense like a meta time
at a time of some sort but people don't
fully appreciate but that wouldn't be
time it wouldn't be tolerance you're
right you're right you're absolutely
right
so in this universe the fact that we can
say that the universe has an age of
whatever 13.8 billion years is only
because our universe is highly symmetric
you look at one chunk of the universe
over here and another chunk over here on
an average their properties are the same
and that weren't the case there would be
no notion of time across even our
universe because of this symmetry of
appearance you're saying we can justify
beliefs say we are all experiencing the
same age of this universe that's right
but if we looked over there and stuff
was being born
and over here stuff was dying out of
proportion yeah we would be forced to
say there's not one coherent time across
the space-time continuum right you see
because Einstein as we're all familiar
with taught us that if you're moving
time ticks off at a different rate if
you're near a black hole time ticks off
at a different rate so you should ask
yourself when people say the universe is
thirteen billion years old according to
which clock right if those clocks are
moving or if they're near a black hole
or a strong gravitational field they'll
tick off time to different rates and the
way we get out of that conundrum is what
you're saying the overall uniformity
means that on those clocks that are
experiencing basically the same physical
conditions they're gonna experience time
the same your clock your clock pantomime
I love it man I've never in my life
wished that I smoked weed so now I know
why they do it man so we got Braille it
will land this plane so two final
questions so if we're asking what was
around before the Big Bang you say maybe
there was this bubble bath yeah big
bangs then that just pushes that
question a little further what was
around before the bubble bath or it may
push it infinitely far back that's a
possible way that could be Turtles all
the way down the other idea that does
come out of string theory initially is
that maybe our universe is a slice of
space floating in a larger cosmos right
higher dimensions of strength you allow
for that freedom so our universe is like
a slice of bread and a big cosmic loaf
that may have other slices which would
be other universes I bring that up
because there's a theoretical
description I'm ignore these guys
[Laughter]
now slice of bread I got you
all right with just a bread loaf
universe exactly and there's a way of
describing the Big Bang where it's
actually arising from the collision of
these two universes it's knowing we
called the Big Bang or the it's called
the big splat right so a little more
evocative way of thinking about it in
which case before the Big Bang before
the big splat would just be these two
giant sheets of space slamming into each
other and they created yet a subsequent
big match that's right it's a cyclic
universe it happens over and over and
over again through these collisions so
then what's before our Big Bang it would
just be an era of the universe similar
to this potentially but was just a
different part of the cycle so therefore
and my last question to you the very
distant future universe where we're
accelerating as whatever rate it is does
what you're saying now effect that very
distant universe it can absolutely
because if for instance we're talking
about cyclic universe no but much slice
of bread is getting bigger your slice of
bread is getting bigger but that other
slice may be coming toward you so a
trillion years from now we may get hit
again be completely obliterated how will
we know if another slice of bread is
coming towards us that's the thing we
won't well Brian Greene thank you for
totally working with our heads thank you
for a second
so we're gonna wrap up this part of the
show before I hand the baton over to
neuroscientist Heather Berlin one of our
Startalk all-stars and while she comes
out but before that happens we are going
to have a special musical interlude Oh
musical interlude oh sweet we are going
to have a special performance by Bob Bob
Brinkman Bob Rickman come on out all
right
buhbuh you're a science rapper
I am a science rapper as such things do
exist that's the thing is the thing now
you will demonstrate that now let's all
hope so all right they gave me one song
to demonstrate the science rap exists
and all this physics stuff is gonna mix
with neuroscience and pretty soon we're
gonna start talking about freewill and
as a rap arter artist who's been at this
for over a decade you got to get into
freestyle so I'm about to do a freestyle
interpreting a lot of what was discussed
for this last half-hour and I want you
to think about this either every word
they said and every word I'm about to
say was predetermined since our Big Bang
on our slice or there is some kind of
free will possible all right hit it now
I'm from Western Canada when I was a
young rapper picture of myself on MTV
this is the rap I always pictured myself
taking listen to this lyric it is in
freestyle it's written
I wrote it of my own free will it was my
decision every intimate constituent part
of it was delivered I considered had a
scripted and had a standard delivery I
wanted to get up on stage and do a lot
of damage and talk about how all the
universes were like a big sandwich and I
could just step up here and do some
things that are drunk on beads and find
out why astrophysics makes people feel
hungry that was forethought but that
doesn't mean nothing comes before
thought look at the source of your
thoughts you might find the doors block
if every decision is made in a part of
my brain that's invisible to me that's
well but with the subliminal origin I'm
not thinking this III see I break it
down I'll show you the freestyle basics
you can't see me all you can see is the
imprint of my radiation see what I'm
saying that's the way that I spend hours
looking for me is looking for in the
university first star but what am I
doing here why am i choosing to Busta
Rhymes am i a puppet on the street who
could not have done otherwise a slave to
my subliminal of amygdala reptilian
forces with no self control up in my
neocortex [__] you're trying to bust
raps I could no more stop than Neil
could shave off his mustache I'm trying
to figure that out maybe perhaps it
could happen but we're all stuck up in
this quantum bubble bath I can't move
even in the option
shoes I couldn't stop if I wanted
astounded the molecules that choose
words and deeds not wants and moons
freedom is like a muscle it's only
strong when it's used I can't stop well
that probably could but I probably
shouldn't cuz right now I gotta kick a
rat and make it really good and maybe
maybe interpret everything that they
talked about a second ago all right
let's do a little rewind y'all people
could be checking the flow see I'm gonna
drop this and say everything clearly I'm
five years from stardom like Brian
explained to the string theory on the
next every word I spit is peer review
something you can check like the
literature it's a freestyle now as I
spit it at you indeed that's the place
that I take it breaking down the basics
yes check it out people always felt them
I'm gonna get on the Big Bang Theory so
I could get dissed by Sheldon
that's about to happen asta cameo and
Bubba briefly coming through right now
with nothing with a damaged inflow yeah
check it I'm gonna have to come spark in
it I'm cooking it's not gonna get the
same reaction as it did with Neil when I
say is there a house full of Brooklyn no
I screwed it up that's okay
I'm just blazed and then that's the way
that we say it where I come from I'm
Canadian trying to bust the rap so I'm
gonna say a shout-out to the plaid shirt
right there strong when it's used well I
can stop I can stop if I want the
question is why would I want to stop I
could stop it's just not recommended at
least not till this song is ending
because I spent a lot of time training
my brain-derived at the drop of a dime
that's the kind of freedom I could claim
this mind freedom isn't a metaphysical
state at the level of atoms it's a
collection of talents each of us can
develop and manage freedom evolved
evolution gave us the building blocks
absolute freedom maybe not but more than
the digger wasp and more than prefrontal
cortex lesion patients living today I'll
take the freedom of God over the non
freedom of Phineas Gage freedom is
having a brain that can reject options
detect Impostors god sucker punches like
boxers freedom is having a brain that
can navigate obstacles in a continuous
exploration
the adjacent possible a brain that's
free enough to recognize goals and
pursue them and recognize the reasons
why even if it's prone to illusions
freedom you can now be tried as an adult
free will it's similar to freestyle it's
a learn about the termina stick deep
down but even if every syllable has a
physical cause freedom is just the
belief that I should still get some
apply
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you fantastic Oh Oh a bottle
so what put part of Harlan's were you
from one three nine and Lenox that's the
danger zone can you tell by the way I
said is the house somewhere around
Brooklyn yeah yeah yeah in the house
right so you're actually Canadian yeah
from Vancouver that's a little just a
little creepy I think I don't know it's
a good it's good but I think it's it's
it's it's the universality of the medium
that I think it's speaking to us all
where you want to express yourself it
comes out it comes out just how you feel
it in that moment the question is if you
imagine hip-hop culture spreading to
Western Canada and then getting adapted
in coming back to Brooklyn would you
imagine it sounding any different than
what I just can't be black anymore I'm
gone
cuz you will you not be okay so that was
a piece from an off-broadway production
I'm doing hip hop theater very inspired
by Hamilton it's called the rap guide to
consciousness and it's all neuroscience
cognitive psychology tonight you had
leave here tonight to perform that the
show starts in 45 minutes get the hell
out of here Soho playoffs so hole
Playhouse downtown is running until the
end of April I hope y'all can come see
it dude thanks for all right Thank You
Neil
that is my favorite rapper now jay-z I
never heard jay-z say anything about his
prefrontal cortex there's some good
vocabulary running out man that was
serious man that's to be clear he did
that in rehearsal yeah and 5% of it was
the same the rest was completely
invented in that moment yeah I was
ambushed so do talk about my mustache
see he knew better than to do that in
rehearse our next segment is gonna be
star talk Allstars where I take a back
seat and we bring on the host one of our
many talented star talk all-stars
neuroscientists Heather Berlin Heather
come on out
[Music]
so Heather is your show okay
go for it all right Neil you can take a
back seat and I don't think so you don't
know me very well so welcome to Startalk
all-stars at BAM
I'm your host Heather Berlin I'm a
cognitive neuroscientist I'm based here
in New York at the Mount Sinai School of
Medicine so Neil Brian thanks for being
my guest tonight and we're gonna add
chopped forget about your just ingrained
in my mind we've become one we've become
chuck my co-host for bringing all of the
wonderful scientific insights and comic
relief thank you for being here so so
wonderful huh so we're gonna talk a
little bit about the intersection
between neuroscience and physics talk a
little bit about consciousness time and
free will so we're just going to keep it
light so nice we Willy right yeah freak
freewill it's not that kind of show
[Music]
you're like my subconscious but I just
kind of try to keep it baby but it keeps
coming up yes that's a very good plan so
actually Brian you Mont you want to
tweet it you said free will is this way
you're gonna quote a tweet of 9:40 in
front of this guy okay that's like
saying I play baseball in front of Babe
Ruth right music in front of Mozart
right
oh good your tweets matter your tweets
matter like free a free will all tweets
matter yes
not all tweet hmm not all tweets blue
tweets matter okay so so you said free
will is the sensation of making a choice
the sensation is real but the choice
seems illusory laws of physics determine
the future so I had to say that you it
was determined from the Big Bang
what does physics have to say about free
will well it's not definite because you
don't fully know the laws of physics but
the laws of physics that we currently
have at our disposal have no opportunity
for intercession by human will right I
mean we are a collection of particles
governed by laws that you can write down
and fit on a t-shirt and those laws
don't at any point in the evolution of
the particles say hey can you like tell
me now what to do person mm-hmm they
just determine the future based upon
what things were like in the past the
brain can't can't there be an emergent
property of that collection of molecules
that we can call freewill
just because because the emergent
property if we understands it's a
feature of an ensemble that cannot be
deduced by the study of the individual
like ants like ants you study one ant
it's a high ant you'll shake your hand
you have no idea that a thousand dance
together gonna make an ant mound right
or a thousand termite make a termite
mound right with it birds will flock you
have no way to pretty Allen if free will
doesn't physics if so in other words if
it doesn't exist at the level of physics
could it not exist at the level of
biology psychology that's right so so
it's a very good point and it really
depends on what your definition of free
will is right normally the intuitive
definition is things could have been
different and I could have made a choice
for things to turn out differently and
if that's your definition of free will
does that
resonate with your perspective for you
well then I don't see any way to square
that with the laws of physics because
anything that you do is your particles
executing some kind of motion and the
motion of your particles in your brain
in your body have no opportunity to
allow you as a conscious being to direct
them what force could possibly that
direction come from is that the
electromagnetic force
well that one we understand from Maxwell
is that the gravitational force we
understand that one from Einstein is
that the nuclear force is those we
understand from the standard model of
particle physics what force could you
possibly exert on your particles that
goes against or goes beyond those that
emerge from the equations of physics
that's the issue could our free will
thrive in the probabilistic description
of quantum physics no not as we
currently understand it and and that's a
natural made me fight you here yeah
we've done this before what we did
actually yeah I grabbed this power but
we were wrestlers in high school
different weight categories I should
have said it's possible but I consider
it highly unlikely so so there is a
puzzle right now in quantum physics that
has been on the table for fifty
seventy-five years and we don't know the
answer to this puzzle that's why I have
to couch my remarks with a little bit of
uncertainty and that puzzle is this
quantum theory says that you can only
predict the probability of one outcome
or another right 50% chance electron
here 50% chance there yet when we
measure the electron we always find it
either here or there right one or the
other so how do you go from the fuzzy
probabilistic haze of many possibilities
to the single definite reality that we
all experience in everyday life we still
don't know how to bridge that gap so
within that if consciousness somehow
plays a role in picking out one outcome
from the probabilistic haze then sure
then freewill might come for the ride
no no you just said probabilistically
the particle can be here or there yes
but if you measure it it is only in one
place yes so my act of thought yeah is I
want to go I want jeez burger that's the
particle in this state and I want to
cheese verb am the particles they don't
buy right thank you see cuz why you put
because it's random there's nothing that
you did to pick one outcome because you
wanted it because you willed it because
it was your desire and yet your
intuition is you had the cheeseburger
because you chose it if it comes from a
random process that's like throwing the
dice and throwing the dice to get an
outcome is not what we mean by free will
okay wait you physicists I'm gonna give
you a neuroscientific perspective good
ok so from a neuroscientific perspective
first of all what's happening at the
quantum level doesn't really scale up to
whether an Iran fires are not right I
mean that indeterminacy but from a
experiments that we've done starting in
the 80s Benjamin Libet did studies where
he said to somebody whatever you feel
like it just press this button and he
measured brain activation and he found
and he said even before they actually
press the button cuz that takes time to
make the movement just let me know where
this little dot is on the clock when you
feel the first inkling of the intention
of wanting to move and that what he
found is about 350 milliseconds before a
person even had that conscious intention
there was a gearing up of brain
activation right so then leap forward to
current times we do now emerging
experiments where we can say to a person
so if people know yeah you measure
people's brains for a living that's my
job that's what I do
yes ok I would be no help to you my
unconscious here again it's always
button in and you know we need you we
need you but you can measure using fMRI
which looks at blood flow to different
parts of the brain functional functional
residents imaging basically looking at
blood flow as a proxy to neurons fire
the blood is gonna go where the neurons
are firing cuz it may need energy so we
can say to you okay just choose left or
right or that hamburger or not and
cheeseburger cheeseburger cheeseburger
he chose to put cheese on we can say we
can predict up to 10 seconds before you
even have the conscious inclination of
your intention which you're going to go
left or right or cheese or no cheese
right so at that level I like to say
yeah sure we have free will but we're
just not conscious of it right the brain
is making these decisions all the time
and we have this illusion of free will
but the question really is is why do we
have the solution why did we evolve this
illusion is it important if we didn't
have it would it change our behavior
yeah I mean it strikes me that it gives
us that sense of control that presumably
out in the Savannah you know fifty
thousand years ago a hundred thousand
years ago made the difference between
surviving and not if you're invested in
how things turn out and feel that your
decisions can affect how things turn out
you're more attentive you're more
engaged it's something that matters to
you more and presumably something like
that or some parallel story like that
suggests why we have this illusion
you're less likely to be eaten yes
that's the point that's the point well
so so you both agree with one another
with each other that some physics point
of view it's deterministic you didn't
use that word but I'm putting it in your
in your mouth I mean it's okay on the
radio and live show and so Heather so
your your results are consistent with
his basically yeah yeah yeah I think
from both a physics perspective and a
neuroscience perspective we come to the
similar conclusion that it's an illusion
that free will is an illusion even
though we really feel like it's not and
actually studies have been done which
when you tell people that free will is
an illusion and you start giving them
subsequent tests they're more likely to
cheat on a math test they're more likely
to act in unethically so the fact that
we have this belief those who have had
it actually
are better able to survive in the system
a long line since we're likely to behave
role however we also have evolved there
to be cheaters right and they can win
and it's over for all cheaters no one
would win but if we just ask Tom Brady
[Laughter]
and Chuck he looks so deflated at the
end of that game so Heather is there a
let me ask you a blunter question right
does it even matter if that you know
this if we all feel like we have free
will I want to believe that I've go to
school and get a good job and behave and
I want to believe all that well I have
you told me I shouldn't believe it that
if I if one day I end up in prison that
was predetermined from the Big Bang and
Wayne right now that was predetermined
meant to be from the Big Bang it was
meant to be I don't know how this got so
sexy but Frank kicking one's ass is not
a literal stickier than asking someone
to kick it means just winning a fight
[Laughter]
born and raised in New York City so
what's a Stuyvesant High School so he's
homegrown oh nice and grown wait that
predetermine ISM that you were just
talking about okay let's say for
instance that you do accept that and
then that leads to fatalism was that
also predetermined so the fact that you
were given this information that well
I'm not really in charge of my own
decisions my brain is making these
decisions based upon these neural
synaptic transitions that happen within
my mind and so I just let that happen
and then I say okay because of that I
don't give a damn about everything and
just let it all go was that
predetermined yep Chuck put out a really
awesome question right there and it just
got a one-word answer at least stretched
out your answer I'm a guy a break
happy to so so you know often people
when they encounter these ideas and you
must have heard this too people say okay
then I'm not gonna do anything sit on my
couch and what does it matter it was
right but you see that's a mixing of two
distinct views on one question you see
if you think that you're making a free
choice to sit on your couch then you
feel like well now I am going to give in
to this and I'm just going to sit there
but if you do that it was determined so
exactly what you're asking if you choose
to sit on your couch it's not that you
made a volitional choice it was set in
place and if that's what was gonna
happen that's what's gonna happen so but
then by that particular measure all
information that we receive
then predetermines everything that we do
that's really what you're saying
yes absolutely uh and and moreover but
you know to just give this a little bit
more color I think you know your view
heather's you and Bob don't me explain
her view okay deterministic
[Laughter]
bama's description I think really at
least helps me when I think in those
terms which is it's not that free will
is the intuitive one that we're talking
about here free will really is the fact
that we're able to carry out this
amazing spectrum of behaviors we can
walk we can talk we can sing we can come
up with ideas the fact that they had an
earlier cause maybe even back at the Big
Bang Timmy doesn't take anything away
from creativity it doesn't take anything
away from originality it doesn't take
anything away from having a sense of
authorship over your own actions
because you're the most immediate cause
of those actions they emerge through you
through your particles your particles
and your brain are configured in such a
way that when certain stimuli hit your
body you said and do certain things the
fact that it's determined who cares this
so there's different views of freewill
okay there's not there's not just
determinism and non determinism there
are different there's compatibilism
which is what that is yeah yeah yeah and
compatibilism is saying that the world
it is deterministic but we also have
free will within that because of these
probabilities and the other question
getting kind of to what you were saying
is that so then people throw their hands
there okay if there's no such thing as
free will then I can do whatever I want
I can go murder someone it doesn't
matter it wasn't predetermined however
we have that's really important we have
evolved the capacity to have
self-control as other animals but in
particular we have the largest
percentage of prefrontal cortex than any
other species which is the part of the
brain that has that ability to control
our innate impulses so we hold people
accountable for their actions
to the degree to which they have the
capacity to have self-control therefore
children are less responsible for their
crimes than adults or people who have
prefrontal lesions or severe psychiatric
illness so those children don't have a
fully developed prefrontal until about
the age of 25 so guys it's 35 yeah let
me ask both of you something because you
both have to think about this if since
we're talking about the brain pre
determining something you do you talk
about the Big Bang pre determining all
future events then is the fact that we
experience time is that itself an
illusion hmm I'm gonna say yes time is
an illusion the way we experience it now
I'm not talking from the physics
perspective right but the way humans
experience time is an illusion because
it's very easily manipulated
so for example in experiments we can
take something called trance magnetic
transcranial magnetic stimulation which
is basically transcranial current
transcranial magnetic stimulation you
you put a magnet and you can kind of zap
different parts of the brain and
temporarily knock them out people let
you do this to them you do all sorts of
things me honest I'm kind of Glee stick
a magnet on their head okay and what
happens we can manipulate for example we
have you do an action like you can press
the button whenever you want kind of
like that let me know when you had the
intention to do it and then we see when
you do it and then we zap you just after
you do it zap you little stimulation
[Laughter]
simulation of the brain and what it does
is we can move back in time your
perception of when you had the intention
we can move forward in time your
perception of when you did the action
okay so that's one way we can manipulate
time you can manipulate time when you're
in various different states of
consciousness when you have particular
types of brain damage especially to the
prefrontal cortex your perception of
time will speed up we're trying to
understand what parts of the brain are
related to time perception and when
they're damaged your time perception
changes or when you have certain
psychiatric illnesses even during the
creative state when you're in that kind
of flow state like when Baba gets into
his flow and he's rapping we I've looked
at his brain in the scanner and other
rats let you do this why do you think I
married it did he know before he married
you that the hell she made him marry her
[Applause]
the real question is will try to dodge
this fact we know all right the real
question is did he write a rap about
neuroscience because he married a
neuroscientist or did he marry a
neuroscientist because he wanted to
write a rap about neuroscience we'll
never know i'ma tell you what I know and
no disrespect to Baba or my wife of 20
years but he married you because you're
hot that's one thing that every man is
predetermined he tells me he was more
attracted to my brain but I'll leave it
at that and i'ma tell you he's lyin in
the scanner yes she put him in the
scanner while he's rapping while he's
rapping and we actually found a distinct
pattern of brain activation where he
during the improvised state versus when
he's doing a memorizer out he gets
decreased activation in the part of the
brain called the dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex which has to do with
our sense of self and time and place so
when you're in these flows me actually a
part of wrinkle the dorsal lateral
prefrontal could you make up your mind
where this thing is in the head I'm kind
of with you because just like dorsal
check all over here
[Laughter]
to the brain that we need to describe
and exquisite these I won't even ask you
about your physics term is that you all
use so it's turned down right and then
so that's why when people are in this
flow state it feels as if it's coming
through them from someplace else because
they lose their sense of agency but they
also lose their sense of time and we
also know in people if you knock out
with transcranial magnetic stimulation
that part of the brain they little
affect their perception of time so time
is a creation of the brain it's an
illusion just like anything else and the
other interesting fact is that people
without any brains em it's just healthy
people actually have a slower subjective
sense of time than the actual clock time
so we're not very accurate at telling
clock time so we have our own kind of
internal pace when I was a kid I did a
really geeky thing just because I could
I trained myself to count seconds
precisely and
Oh what are you talking about me oh
that's not geeky at all and my personal
best my personal best was I counted 89
seconds when 90 seconds have passed and
I used to do it with soft watches I
almost got an applause for that thank
one other and so so so so bright I just
tried to match real time yeah
but she's saying it's like it's where
the brain can be manipulated think about
is there such thing as real time I don't
I mean like I just think it's an
illusion that we experiment is there
actual well I mean you know from the
standpoint of physics there is a
conception of time because that's what
allows change to occur so when people
say from a physics standpoint the time
is an illusion I don't really know what
they mean but it is the case that our
experience of time which you say that
you can manipulate which is quite
interesting with magnets yeah exactly
you know experience of time does not
give us insight into the way time
actually works because once you learns
that time for me is not the same as time
for you if we're in motion or for
experiencing different gravitational
fields these are measurable differences
between how your watch and my watch will
take off time based upon what we're
doing and where we are that's
counterintuitive we've never experienced
that it took a genius of Einstein to
come along and reveal it so I would say
that our experience of time gives us a
misrepresentation of how time actually
behaves the time is real but for every
one of us we are prisoners of the
present eternally transitioning from our
past to our future Jesus which is in the
show right was like guess we had a
looking into the future there might be
ways that we can we can do things now
like implants electrodes in the brain
right and stimulate certain parts more
you may talk about this because the
magnet wasn't good enough we can control
it with remote control Bob you weren't
this off stage controlling Bob if we
could and theoretically we could do this
in the not-too-distant future go in and
a plant electrode and affect your
perception of time such that every
moment appears to last an eternity well
you could fast-forward the ones you
don't like you can keep the relief that
was in black mirror I saw this drive man
yeah
but the question it would be the
question would be would you want that
implant would you want that because I
happen to think that you know having me
to experience both the good and the bad
that happened the fact that it's
temporal and that there's this limit and
that it's our most valuable resource
gives life meaning but suppose you could
find the moments in time were the places
in the brain where you're most creative
and then make that be your biggest your
most sustained experience well anyway
the creativity map into this
conversation yes when you're creating
the party brain that are normally active
when they're clicking off time are
downregulated when you're in that
creative flow state so people time
doesn't seem to exist self doesn't seem
to exist it's a very pleasurable State
people strive to get a great brain and I
could agree on this when you're cranking
out some equation you you forego
personal hygiene you don't know that
you're hungry you don't know and because
and you don't know how much time is
elapsed and you'll most likely Ya Ya Ya
Ya Sunday but you also feel it feels as
if you're tapping into something greater
as if you are outside something greater
than yourself because your sense of self
is turned down so in those moments I
would argue that we feel eternal in a
sense because time is not existing and
it is very pleasurable but do you want
to be in that state all the time you
have control over it if you had control
[Laughter]
like a real-life version of get out
lay me down on a table now stick it to
the floor well I welcome any of you come
on in
but yeah so anyway I would argue that
our sense of time is what gives us
meaning and there are some patients you
get lesions where they are just
literally living in the moment they
cannot see the future and they cannot
think of the past there's someone who
has a certain type of visitors of the
present without vision right you see
because you see where prisoners
depression I say we're not prisoners of
the present because we can see into the
future in the past there are true people
who there's a man he a certain type of
brain damage where every minute he keeps
a diary and he just keeps writing I am
now just for conscious for the very
first time right now I'm just conscious
for the first time now I'm just awake
the first time and it's just each minute
because he has no vision he can't look
in the future and he can't see the past
it's only the now he's a drag that made
that happen no I was the type of brain
damage that I borrow some money from him
wait one interesting thing of that story
though just just to give it meaning
he had damage to his hippocampus which
is involved in memory but the one thing
he did remember there's an episode of
family got called big man on the
hippocampus he's by the way really I've
never seen it whoa the famous I know I
was in that episode yeah
he was referenced in it or something all
right the big man on the hip again no no
no no no yeah um the thing that remains
stable those every time his wife would
come to visit him and this was over the
course of years he would recognize her
and see her like it's the first time
he's seeing her in a million years and
say oh it's so good to see you I'm so
happy to see whatever and that lasted
for years and years and it was the only
thing that remained constant and the
other thing was that he was a
professional pianist and whenever he'd
get in front of me on Oh and get into
this mode he could actually just play a
whole piece now was he wearing was he
aware that his wife was putting magnets
on but the one thing is this we control
the electrodes right now the question is
can you control them yourself yeah
that's why I hesitate I we haven't
gotten to that point yet because you
don't want people going home when you
get there singing themselves
you know but let me get to that point
you know I'll give you so heavy we're
about to lose Brian before I go to her
our sports verse he says so Brian you
have any sort of concluding reflective
thoughts uh nope any freely said that so
Brian I like what was it
Einstein or John Wheeler who said of
time time is invented to make motion
look simple
I hear wheeler said time was invented so
that everything doesn't happen at the
same moment oh you can spread it out
yeah and Einstein said that the
distinction between past present and
future is only an illusion however
persistent and I'm not a leaf thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
Brian Greene everybody good job
well
[Applause]
[Music]
for those of you who are uninitiated
playing with science is a sports science
mashup where Neal likes to say we're
jocks and geeks collide and I like to
say with without any concussions by
geeks because you know when Johnson
geeks collide only one person suffers in
that collision yeah one person walks
away one person walks away the other one
does not and normally in high school I
was a geek jock a geek job yeah yes yeah
so a wrestler yeah yeah so but i but I
intellectually I associated with the
geek averse okay but anytime I saw a
geek sort of get beaten up or you know
bullied that was my sort of superhero I
was like the geeks need me now I would
go and I would just you know so I felt
this urge to protect the geek asphere as
a high school what's the superhero name
for that I don't know I don't know it
needs one yeah I believe it's the Tyson
nadir
that's very cool yeah so who do you have
so but before we get into our guest who
is hahaha just so so so awesome I
actually I'm going to use a different
word who is such a superb guess he Tate
he said that because anytime I hear say
awesome he said it would be awesome if
you could pass the salt and I would say
it when I grew up the word awesome with
applied to curing polio walking on the
moon and there's a next generation that
has no concept of how to use that word
and I blame the lego movie
you didn't see it right everything is
awesome okay okay let me just say first
of all I can't tell you how long I've
been waiting to do that on stage but
normally this show is co-hosted with
Gary O'Reilly who is a former
professional soccer player and the
co-host of playing with science and he
is a currently a broadcaster and he
resides in the UK unfortunately his
flight was canceled and so he could not
be here I'm snowing and it was snowing
in the UK no was snowing here and
unfortunately he could not be here so we
but he is listening right now not right
now but he will be listening to this
broadcast so if we could all give a
round of applause to Garry O'Reilly
and so what we do here is we explore the
science of sport and to help us do that
today we have an incredible guest who is
a former Olympic silver medalist and she
is also wait how many times how many
times was it oh god I got I got a look
at these notes because I want to get it
right
five-time world champion medalists
please welcome the incredible so excited
to join the fun Chuck what did she get
her medals in I took it for granted that
everybody would know because you're
sasha Cohen but of course is a figure
skater and and I a damn good one and not
just a figure skater because you're also
an incredible ballerina and gymnast all
of those things like rolled in and then
strap skates on and do it all exactly I
started in gymnastics I wanted sick
hip-hop my mom directed me towards
ballet once you have a job what's wrong
[Laughter]
still my favorite white white science
wrapper okay so so that was how I got
started I started in gymnastics because
I was basically a bundle of energy and I
destroyed the house they're like how can
we calm you down so I got put into
gymnastics for about three hours a day
every day and when I was five years old
I was doing hundreds of jumping jacks
push-ups V ups and when I got home I was
a very well behaved yup that's very
impressive I got the space-time
continuum
just leave it there so we of course have
had the Berlin hero dr. Heather Berlin
who is going to break down the
neuroscience because there's a lot of
neuroscience that goes into pretty much
every athlete correct yeah like will you
talk about the brain and the discipline
and the they call it muscle memory but
it really is well it's actually called
procedural memory so basically when
you're first learning and you'll
probably have had this experience the
moves or whatever it may be you have to
really focus and you're using parts of
your prefrontal cortex you need
conscious focus even learning to tie a
shoelace for the first time and then
over time over repetition and discipline
to do it all those many times it starts
to become implicit or unconscious and it
moves into the basal ganglia which is
the sort of subcortical part of the
brain and it becomes this procedural
memory or what we call muscle memory
yeah and it's like riding a bike and
then once you get it into that implicit
state if you become too self aware of
what you're doing like oh exactly how
should I hit that tennis ball or do it
will mess up your flow so I imagine that
you practice it so much that when you go
into a routine you're almost going on
autopilot right you want to get to that
point at which your body knows what it's
doing and you don't have to think about
it because the thinking messes it up
because Yogi Berra said it baseball
90% of the game is half mental no it's
true and I think that's where a lot of
elite athletes get in trouble and I've
it's happened to me on you know several
occasions is where you train your body
your something over and over and over
but then you have this one moment and
you're like I can't leave it to chance
and so you get your mind involved
because you also have you know days that
you you know you're only practicing an
hour a day once you're at competition
and then you're just thinking about it
over and over and this one moment
arrives and it's very hard to put away
you know the monkey mind because it
really wants to be there to help you but
it's like too many cooks in the kitchen
exactly and when you turn down that part
of the it's basically the dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex where and that's the
inner critic and oh my god which I do
and then if you can manage to turn that
down and just enter into the flow state
and lose yourself that's when you really
perform exactly yeah you better watch
Heather she'll tell you to sink it to
the ice Leo you yesterday actually I
heard you talking to somebody at another
thing we were doing when you would
saying that you skate or you did
something at the ice rink where you wore
figure skates what didn't you know I
spent the time in high school as a rink
guard but not with hockey skates no
hockey unusual yeah yeah the regard is
like more more aggressive with with
hockey skates but I have figure skating
figure skates I'm just trying to figure
this out and maybe you can tell me
because that topic can hurt you that's
why you had it yeah yes II figure skate
there's like eat in the front of figure
skates and so yeah I threw some thugs
who came on who were like yeah hockey
thugs game was so tough you know
beefy thuggy guys and rather than fight
them I just challenged them to erase
from one end of the ice to the other and
everyone parted ways and they're having
hockey skates oh so they got it like
press their feet left and right so go
forward yeah I had I figured I just went
up on my toes and [__]
[Laughter]
so then shut up after that but yes I
deeply appreciate your craft as a figure
skater myself you do the next episode on
the rink
we'll race oh yeah
meet me outside on the rink the figure
skate time in a tutu are you aware of
the physics that because they called
figure skating physics on ice there's
there's so much - are you aware of the
physics when you're skating or are you
aware of it at all I think you are aware
of it but you don't think of it in terms
like physics you know you'd the way that
you define is like this like hyper body
awareness and you can feel when you take
off for a jump if you don't have enough
speed if you slightly throw your
shoulder too much and you can feel in
the air that you're you're off-kilter
and then you're gonna go down hard and
you also know that if you're doing a
single a double a triple or a quad
exactly how much torque you have to put
in when you leave the ice because that
is what determines like how fast you
will rotate and if you'll be able to
complete you know certain number of
rotations up in the air so torque is a
force that sets something into rotation
and otherwise it's just a force giving
acceleration to an object so you have
force that goes in a straight line and
then you have torque which is a force
turning Sun so yeah so there you are
it's a force you were putting between
your body you're skating the ice so that
you can rotate to launch it like to
begin it and the same with spinning and
that's something you know you'll kind of
go into a spin slow and then you'll
you'll glide in and you'll you'll ride
the edge and then you'll take the right
side of your body and you'll like you'll
snap it to begin the spin and then
you'll use your arms and legs to
increase your speed or slow it down
oh my god so alright so I've learned how
to physically
I did so here's what I would love to do
if for those of you who are listening
and do not have the benefit of visual
because everybody is here if you could
stand up and just show us the actual but
you have to talk it through because
people are listening at home if you can
show us the physicality of what happens
when you're doing that motion and the
kneel if you can break down exactly
what's happening from a physical
standpoint I think that would be really
cool I'm making this up as I go along so
we can pretend like we're we're the
Olympic announcers she's doing so Sasha
:
she's wearing high heels at this moment
okay so what happened there's there's
two instances right there's a jump and a
spin I feel like everyone if anyone's
watched any figure skating is somewhat
aware of the difference when you leave
the ice and one you don't the jump you
leave the ice so for instance like I
will start with a salchow and so it's
something where you're gonna take off
backwards and you're gonna be gliding on
the inside edge of your left foot and
you're gonna determine how much speed
you want to get going in right so I'll
be doing crossovers and running and
running and going fast speed right and
then people have different entrances but
say like when I many many many years ago
I did a quad salchow and I wanted to get
extra torque so I would do a turn ahead
and then I would set myself here and
then I would use the edge gliding
backwards my the right side of my body
and I would dig in with my left with my
left foot into the ice and whipped this
up and that's what would initiate the
like the momentum and I would leave the
ice push off this topic and then
immediately slap snap the weight over my
right side and based on how much I
followed through with my right arm and
right leg and push down with my left
would determine how fast I would spin
and if it would be a single jump a
double jump a triple jump or a quad wait
can I ask you a question the way you've
just broke it down was a very logical
con
whatever but when you're actually doing
that you're not thinking all those
things are you are you feeling them you
feel it feel it so I think I'm
explaining exactly what I feel right but
it's it's it's like you're very
fine-tuned you know exactly how much
speed you need and you know how much
speed is too much that you'll lose
control that it could turn out great but
you have to get lucky because basically
speed magnifies anything it it helps you
get more height and more torque but if
you are one millimeter off in any
direction and you have extra speed
you're gonna go down really hard or
you're you're your alignment won't be
quite right so people are tended a
little tentative of speed because I can
you know you can go up in flames it's
like it's like putting leverage on your
house it can work out really well or
just can go bust you so so I get huge
gave a brilliant description of how you
give yourself rotational inertia okay
first jump we haven't even gotten to the
spin but however you didn't well okay so
I might amia in physics you generally
break things apart into components and
you put them all together for the one
thing I break this apart you told me how
you gain spin but you have if you're
gonna do a quad you have to be airborne
long enough to complete the quad before
you hit the ground yes so that's part of
it because you'll notice if you've
watched figure skating this past
Olympics you will see some people barely
get off the ice and they can do three
turns and some people get this hot this
high up and they don't complete it three
feet off the ice so it really is the
rotation yourself up got you and then
obviously it goes into like what's your
body type do you have like wide hips how
fast are you spinning and that's why men
rotate faster and generally do a lot
more quads than women do there they spin
faster they've got narrower hips and but
you know women are more flexible so
we've got better spiral see how many
women have done quads you know a couple
of done it in practice and I feel like
maybe like one one or two have done it
and you've done a quad I have you get
its thankfully YouTube exists and it
will always live there Wow I used to do
that now I just so people must have
freaked out I mean did the announcer
lose his [__] I mean I mean it was it
was an exciting moment because you know
people can see when you get really close
or you've double footed or you step up
and when you actually do it and you're
kind of you come down from four turns
and you have to have tremendous amount
of strength and balance to catch
yourself when you come down get out and
so it's this moment it's like it's you
can do it if you're gonna do it
and you have it and it's it's very
exciting it was exciting and the landing
so - when I trained you know you'd work
on explosive muscles for bounce and then
you would also I would jump down off of
boxes this high in order to kind of
learn how to absorb all that pressure
and momentum coming down usually with
the skates on with all five training I
would do it without skates
and then on the ice but then let me get
you a spin because the spin is very
different cuz you're not launching
yourself out and it's something that
goes for much longer it's not fractions
of a second it's a spin you know can be
thirty seconds it can be a minute and
you basically you'll see most people
wind backwards and they're creating this
it's all about torque in the body and
this is why I realize I'm a terrible
skier because it's the opposite and sort
of winding the spring your widest okay
and so my hips are going to the left and
my shoulders are going to the right a
lot of ABS what abs and poor work yes
and then and then so then you step in
and you ride this outside edge and then
again you do the same whit momentum for
a jump except you don't take off and
then you spin generally if I wasn't in
heels I could do more spins and then
once you're there you can you'll keep
this momentum and then as I would bring
in my arms and my legs I can just
insanely increase the speed of my spin
and likewise if all of a sudden I wanted
to slow it down I would just open up and
you would see the rotations just kind of
almost stopped and so in that way I was
aware of physics but for figure skaters
we would think about it more in terms of
like body awareness of you know where
your hips are what torque you need once
you have to look good doing it yes right
cuz you're being judged and what color
you look get in right right there other
dimensions of the analysis of the rank
of the scores
exactly right so you actually yes can
you tell us what is happening when she
does that so the physics yeah yeah so so
if you
tell you is this prince charming is
never coming back so in physics here's
the deal so if you set yourself rotating
alright so I'll do that right now okay
so so here I am rotating okay so this
speed
wait don't applaud yet you don't know
what's about to come okay so so so you
just so you can calculate how much
angular so in physics you might remember
from your physics class if you had it or
you right so everything that happens in
a straight line you can think of in a
rotation so there's a force the
rotational counterpart is torque there
is mass the rotational counterpart is
moment of inertia there is you also have
momentum and the rotational counterpart
is just angular momentum so here's the
thing once you start rotating your
angular momentum is constant okay it's
constant so if I start spinning and you
kept you calculate the angle momentum by
okay here it is it is the mass of
whatever your body is which in this case
would be the biggest figure skater
here's the point so your your hands your
hands have a certain mass okay and
they're rotating out at this distance so
you have part of your body mass away
from your axis of rotation
oh okay so if you you can calculate how
much angular momentum that is now watch
if I bring any part of my body closer to
my axis of rotation then one of the
terms in your angular momentum drops it
so so
what happens is the distance to your the
the axis of rotation drops but your
angular momentum stays the same so
something has to increase
so uh-huh okay because when you multiply
these numbers you have to get the same
answer every time okay so if I start
changing the distance of the mass of my
body to my axis and I make it smaller I
have to spin up nice and so so there you
have allow me yes yes ma'am okay so I
will spin and then okay and then let
just like she said
good what she needs right right in there
right sir
so your spinning you speed up but then
you can stop it by just putting your
mask back out so here's here's my
proposal to you okay here we go okay so
so put your arms out okay so your my
skating physics demo in this moment so
you have a certain amount of mass coming
out here all right so it's a weight for
those listening right now sasha has her
arms
spread apart right apart yes and in a
tea formation and go ahead exactly so
it's a certain amount of mass along your
arm and in your hand and you also showed
earlier when you start a spin you might
start with your leg out okay and then
when you bring your leg closer in
towards your axis of rotation you start
spinning faster and okay so we got this
oh I like you haven't okay sorry I
didn't okay so here's my suggestion I
don't know if it's legal next time you
do this I think you can do a Quint is
there such a word there is such a good
Quint five turns now how would you do
that I'm gonna say you get some lead
weight to put in your head when you
start when you start spinning with lead
weights in your hand even if you're
spinning at the same speed that you once
were
you have more mass farther away from
your rotation axis so that as you then
bring the more mass in you will spin
faster and I don't know people will
notice if you're grabbing something
[Laughter]
heavy rings bracelet and LED infuse the
wrist bracelet and you're just it's just
your your your jewelry so what I'm
saying is if you did that the same
gestures you will spin faster and you'll
have to land you have to figure out the
landing but-but-but what you going to
throw this back to you what's that first
spinning this would absolutely work and
it would give me more torque in momentum
when I spin yes
but I think the extra weight would not
allow me to get up as high in the air
and so even if I got extra towards when
I pulled in I would still not be able to
rotate think about that so so this is
one of the interesting physics problems
where there are two variables competing
with one another and you don't know if
one is more powerful than the other or
where they meet to get the best
combination of both and those debts we
get the more interesting complex
problems in physics and in life I have a
neuroscience problem here that I can
address you know why don't you get dizzy
when doing all of these oh yeah so I
have you know Chuck of if we did
so you know there's actually a
neuroscientific explanation for that
for that question so it's interesting
for dumping you know it happens in a
fraction of a second and you you don't
get dizzy she's very quick but spinning
is something where ballet and skating
really diverge you know if you're a
ballerina you're spotting you know like
to the edge of the room and that's how
you're keeping you know you're you're
spotting you mean you pick us you turn
that prevents you from getting dizzy for
ballet for ballet
this is what ballerinas do they always
spot but for for figure skaters you're
spinning so fast and you're not doing
just like kind of one one one you're
literally doing I don't know like 50
turns and you the trick is you have to
stay in the same Center so about like
one to two blade lengths and and I don't
know I think it's like something to do
with your inner ear that if you're not
traveling and you're kind of you're
staying in the same spot even though
you're spinning you don't get dizzy but
from personal experience when you do a
spin and you do a bad spin in which you
get a deduction for and you're traveling
so you kind of start here and I end up
offstage that would be you get out of
the spin and it's like a cartoon where
you see the stars and you're just like
why where am I and so that's why they
teach you have your Center and don't
travel so explain that inner ear to me
and like you're so your inner ear
consists of these three like fluid
filled tubes right and each one is at a
different orientation so it's meant to
be sensitive to a different orientation
let's say if your head goes up and yes
like this or no or side to side and
within those three dimensions yeah three
dimensions and they're they're
represented within your inner ear and
these little Canalis tubes and within
each of these fluid-filled tubes are
these little hairs that are like sensing
it's almost like seaweed at the bottom
of the ocean so when you move it senses
and sends signals to your brain so if
you think about if you're in a chair
let's say spinning and you're holding a
bottle of water and you're spinning in
this swivel chair and then you stop the
water is going to keep going right
because it built up momentum and the
same thing is happening in your inner
ear so it's telling
brain you're still moving that's why
people get dizzy and also there's it
that's right when you stop spinning you
fall over because you can't keep your
balance because your brain didn't figure
out that you stopped Spain thinks you're
still moving but then there's also
information so it's information reaches
your brain but your muscles are telling
you stuff as well there's proprioceptive
input and there's also visual input
right giving you information what kind
of input was the muscle input
proprioceptive
proprioceptive proprioception yeah it
signals that tell your body's it's
awareness and space so you Bonnie your
brain is getting that information from
your muscles in your joints the inner
ear is telling you you're still moving
and your eyes are giving you information
so that's why they often say and tell me
if they say this to you when you're at
it when you come out of the spin
different than ballerinas you focus each
time they make a turn but you then are
told to focus at a specific point
because you want to have your eyes
telling your brain counteracting what
your inner ear is telling it that it's
still moving that you're not moving any
longer and also what you do I'm sure is
you practice off ice just spinning so
that your brain can habituate so it's
not so much that you're spinning in one
place versus moving although the
movement is gonna cause it to be more
confusing because there's moving in
different directions so it'll be less of
a movement if you're in one space but
that's not what I think is happening I
think you habituate cuz you practice
right your breath is acclimated to space
it's the only so much though right cuz
it's still a physiological effect right
so what you'll see in figure skaters do
is they'll spin very fast and then
they'll slow down and they slow down
they're kind of getting their bearings
easing yourself out of it exactly and
then there's like a trick move that you
do is you spin really really really fast
and you stop and then you give you - you
do it - the music's like but BAM and
then it gives you some like a Mack in
and then you're like
like you built it you know we have these
like these breathers is it true that
your fastest spin in any performance is
the spin your you end on so you don't
have to be graceful and balance eeee
after that it's true people generally do
they're more straining they're more
strenuous like wham bam hit every
position it's like very dramatic at the
very end
also because it takes up a lot of energy
and you want to get your jumping passes
in earlier although you're seeing that
change now along with a new judging
system where you're getting rewarded and
getting more points if you jump after
the halfway mark but generally you want
to end on a big note and so people will
do combination spins where you hit like
six different positions you're in a
camel you're gonna sit spin lay back and
then you're on the other foot and your
legs up so there's we're almost at a
time why is it that from a neurological
standpoint that that is our first kind
of foray into getting high you see
children's spin around what what is
happening there well a lot of what drugs
do is they kind of play with your senses
right so normally we have input coming
in from our senses and and our brain is
organizing in a certain way but when you
kind of mess with your senses in the way
the brain is interpreting them that's
also what drugs tend to do and it feels
it's interesting because it's a
different brain state you know there and
it's not just your inner ear by the way
those inner ear if that information goes
through that little brain in the back
here brain the cerebellum right it's
right in the backyard neck and what's
interesting that is that that has two
times as many neurons as your entire
brain right two times as many neurons so
twice yeah twice two times isn't any
more on but it's unconscious okay and
people who have complete damage to the
Sarah
Belem they are still fully conscious
aware I mean they might have less
coordination they can't do triple axels
and things but they're fully conscious
and aware so we only need basically one
third of our neurons to have conscious
awareness but it's interesting how much
goes into that ability to have balance
and but so but I think the reason why it
feels good is that we like different
sensations we like to be outside of our
normal dream States or creative States
or daydreaming when we're not in that
normal state where the prefrontal cortex
is on and everything's working properly
it's it's fun it's interesting that's
why we like to go on roller coasters or
rides that make us feel weird so
socially when you're performing you're
in an altered mental state according to
this was it maybe that's why I became a
figure skater world is gonna be too much
this game for 20 years that's why you
drink before competitions that is it for
playing with
Olympic medalist Sasha :
[Applause]
[Music]
with silence please give it up the
derry-o rally who is not here and our
catchphrase is this if you play with
fire you get burned you play with
science you could learn it home safely
have a good night